bryce wilson
the 22 year old almost 23 year old from
durham north carolina
threw three no-hitters in high school
when he compiled a 33-4
record one-two pitch how about the start
for bryce wilson
and akunya's on to start the night for
atlanta
he strikes out good pitch down and away
by kershaw
here's one hard hit right at turner out
at second
out at first a rocket hit by ozuna
and the dodgers hadn't played perfectly
one on one out dansby swanson
steps in two for 12 in this lcs
the next is on the inside corner he just
kept pounding him
in and kershaw gets strikeout number two
on the night
runner will go and a pop-up on the
infield good luck
with all that wind it's muncie and he's
able in fair territory to haul it in
edwin rios leads it off no score
third inning that is ripped into right
will it go
back at the wall goodbye
edwin rios the d.h has put the dodgers
on top
here in the third i mean they say he's
joey
i mean light tower power and then that
is a classic
finish bringing ozuna here's the guy the
braves got to get going he is
monster year this year that
is a blast way out of here
this ball game is tied and a couple of
stops
along the way around the bases for
marcelo zuna
he said they had to get him going that
thing got out of here in a blink
needed acuna and ozuna to get busy
tonight so far so good
and it is selfie time yeah it is
there's strike three this kid
bryce wilson two out in the inning
four strikeouts in the ball game who
knew
2-2 went around
[Music]
[Applause]
five strikeouts and in steps
the blistering hot corey seeger
[Music]
and remaining on the mound and why
wouldn't he be bryce wilson
[Music]
that is popped up shallow left
calling for it is riley and how about
bryce wilson
3-2 pitch is over the head of kershaw
what a play but safe the ball gets away
acuna ends up on the ground and may be
in some pain
[Applause]
says he is okay to continue so acuna is
going to go down to second
on the error by [ __ ] hernandez and
freeman
has a chance to put atlanta on top for
the first time tonight and atlanta will
take the lead
digging around third acuna digging into
second
freeman the two switch spots and it's
two to one
atlanta here in the sixth
3-2 pitch that's into left center field
another one
driven in by ozuna cruising in the
second
another double it's three to one atlanta
on top in the sixth
that double by marcelo zuna knocks out
clayton kershaw
first and third with one out on a base
in by ozzie aldeas
here's a base hit down the left-field
line
ozuna scores going to third as aubry's
they're going to bring her around
[Music]
two more runs for atlanta here in the
sixth
and riley grounds one up the middle for
a base hit
here comes swanson at another run it's
6-1
3-2 pitch now and that is a bullet into
center field
on his way to the plate riley he scores
without a play
and they just keep and none it's 7-1
bases loaded and the dodgers trying to
jump
right back into game four one-two pitch
is hit in the air to center field
poche comes in makes the catch tagging
is turner
it's a seven to two game one of the
dugouts either way is going to erupt
base is loaded two
down 2-2 pitch is lined and caught
by ozzie albees martin fired up
and the dodgers get only one and leave
the bases loaded
fourth picture of the night for the
dodgers dylan floro and there's one in
the center
back at the
his second of the night and the braves
get that run right back
it's 8-2 i would say he is
paying dividends for the one-year deal
he signed with the atlanta braves all
season
regular and post
freeman's gonna dump one into center
field the runners were going
so easily scoring is pache and over to
third
is acuna and another rbi for freddie
freeman
ozuna has already had a big night he's
going to
add to it with a base hit into center
another run is on the board and it's a
10 to two ball game here in the eighth
it'll be an elimination game and he'll
be the first of you have to believe
quite a few unless he just dominates and
he's more than capable of that
ball to first and that does it game four
belongs to the atlanta braves